here is this guy charlie crist and
charlie crist has no support in the
state of florida he just has no support
but the media wants you to think he has
support and they will do anything
obviously to stop ron desantis because
ron desantis stands for freedom and you
guys know all about that so they bring
charlie crist on and what's hilarious is
so anna navarro now is going to ask
charlie a couple questions here anna
navarro it turned out it was exposed by
this guy brandon leslie who who i've met
a couple times good guy he found a whole
bunch of tweets of anna navarro's that
he tweeted out at about 10 am right
before the view went live of her saying
the worst possible things about charlie
crist so then that started going viral
so anna felt that she had to really push
charlie chris this is just great james
you've been in 16 elections in the last
three decades and that time you've gone
from a staunch republican
to an independent to a democrat your own
words charlie have come back to haunt
you have been used against you they were
used against you you did a robocall in
2006 which was part of a campaign
republican campaign against you and is
now coming up again and so i'd like us
to hear it and i'd like you to explain
what's the deal so you don't have to
debate the santas you can debate
november
hi this is charlie crist calling to set
the record straight i'm pro-life i
oppose amnesty for illegal immigrants i
support traditional marriage and i have
never supported a new tax or big
spending program i support a
constitutional amendment to protect
traditional marriage and i oppose
adoption by gay couples and i work to
ensure the right to display the ten
commandments in public places floridians
need a consistent conservative governor
that they can trust i would appreciate
your vote on election day thank you so
much and god bless you and god bless
florida
so
yeah
those are your words what would you say
to skeptics like me who think you've
changed parties because you're a
political mercenary and it was out of
out of convenience how should we trust
you how do you convince me i changed
parties because my party changed you
know it started with the rise of the tea
party back in 09 and 2010
and it really has metastasized since
then and you know i just couldn't
stomach it anymore to see
how you know not all republicans i don't
want to paint too broad a brush here
because there's a lot of good
republicans in florida and in our
country
and uh what i understand though is that
the party has changed dramatically from
what it was
when i was a republican and and what
i've seen is that it's so uh
anti-minority frankly this governor is
making it harder for african americans
to vote in my state uh making it harder
for senior citizens like my 90-year-old
father my 87 year old mother male in
balloting is more difficult in florida
now uh and books pardons books spanning
books i mean it goes on and on okay so
you can really just he just reeks of
like they know desantis is going to
crush it they had to put up somebody so
you just find some career politician
loser who will take any position on
absolutely anything but of course the
the the party change not him and the tea
party really was the thing that pushed
him over the edge the tea party which
wanted lower taxes the tea party which
wanted states rights
um you know he's talking about them
becoming anti-minority it's like it's
just so not true do you know how many
cubans and hondurans and all sorts of
people i meet here in florida every day
who absolutely love ron desantis and
they believe in borders and all of these
things so he's just he's just sort of
nothing he the guy is just nothing this
you know what i'm going to make a
commitment on the show today barring
something so cataclysmic so off the
record
uh i am never going to talk about
charlie crist again the election
obviously isn't about what is it now
little less than two months i'm not
going to talk about this guy again
because it's by talk i'm just giving
oxygen to nonsense it's just silliness
but i had to do this because i wanted
just it's just about showing you how the
machine fakes these people